lake natron in northern tanzania
is notorious for killing and preserving
dead animals
if you died in its waters its high
levels of sodium carbonate
would mummify your body but instead of
taking a swim
what would happen if you took a sip
would your insides become mummified
is there any way you could survive
and why could other animals drink this
mummifying water but
not you this is what if
and here's what would happen if you
drank from lake natron
you've decided to try quite a toxic
cocktail
and it has three main ingredients that
could cause
severe damage to you there's the highly
alkaline liquid
created by sodium carbonate and chlorine
lake natron has a ph of 10.5 which
is only slightly lower than the ph of
ammonia
and if that's not enough to scare you
the water also has
microscopic blue-green algae called
cyanobacteria
it tints the lake red and produces
chemicals that can
fatally damage your cells and the
final dangerous ingredient is salt
even if you could survive the burns and
the toxins
the salt would cause your demise
you might be wondering why it would be a
bad idea for you to drink this water
when
you see flamingos quenching their thirst
do not be fooled by the flamingos
these flamingos evolved to survive
despite the unique conditions of lake
natron
their legs are covered in special scales
and their tough skin
protects them from getting burned they
can drink this super hot water
too salty no problem they have special
glands in their head to remove
salt from salt water too much toxic
algae
they don't mind their colorful plumage
comes from a pigment in the algae that
contaminates the water
they're one of the few animals that
thrive in lake natron's toxic
environment
but if you ignore my warning and take a
sip
what would happen as this dangerous
water travels through your body
well right away you'd burn your lips and
tongue
the lake is flooded with underground
water that can be as hot as
60 degrees celsius but this would be
nothing compared to the chemical burns
that you'd experience next
the corrosive water would continue
burning your mouth
esophagus and stomach your insides would
feel like they were on fire and if you
drank enough of this water
the alkaline liquid could burn a hole in
your stomach
your abdominal pain could be crippling
and
while your stomach is burning the
cyanobacteria contaminating the water
would
make you feel nauseous and could give
you diarrhea
to make matters even worse you'd start
feeling very thirsty
lake natron has high levels of sodium
and chlorine
together they can combine to create
sodium chloride
or salt so if you continued drinking the
salty lake nature on water
your body would make you pee more water
than you drank
this would make you dehydrated and the
more salty water you drank
the thirstier and more dehydrated you
would become
eventually you die hopefully you have a
bottle of fresh water nearby
you would probably survive the immediate
and painful consequences of drinking
lake natron's water but
it could leave your liver damaged
forever
and if the water burns a hole in your
esophagus or stomach
you'd need to get medical treatment
right away otherwise you could get an
infection
the toxic algae could cause muscle
weakness joint pain and
a sore throat for a few more days
so leave lake natron to the flamingos
and
stick with the toxin-free fresh water
now if you really feel the need to drink
questionable liquids have you ever tried
to drink
a lava lamp they're so mesmerizing
but that's a story for another
what if
you